we're told that a car with wheel
radius-r moves at a linear velocity V
and this is a bolded V to show that it's
a vector suddenly the car accelerates to
velocity 2v how does the angular
velocity of the wheels change so pause
this video and see if you can figure
this out on your own
alright now let's work through this
together so just to visualize what's
going on let's just draw at least the
front wheel of a car here so let me draw
the wheel first actually so this is the
front wheel of the car and I'll draw the
part of the car so this is our car right
over there it might look something like
look something like that and you got the
windshield right over there so you can
visualize visualize this car so our car
looks something like I got our
headlights and all the rest all right
enough of drawing the car so let's
imagine this car right over here has a
velocity V let's say it's going forward
so let me draw that so it's velocity
I'll just draw it right over here it is
V so this is a velocity of V and since
it's hard to hand draw something bolded
I put a little arrow on it but this is
equivalent to this bolded vector V that
you might see sometimes in your textbook
bold would be a vector or you put an
arrow on it to show it's a vector now I
want to make notation clear if we talk
about the magnitude of this vector and
the magnitude of velocity is just speed
I'm going to denote I'm going to denote
that as just V with it out an arrow on
it and not bolded so this is going to be
the same thing as the magnitude of our
velocity vector which is the same thing
as our speed now let's take a point on
the outer end of our wheel any point on
the outer Nov let's say we take at this
point right over here and the center of
our wheel is right over here so if the
car is moving forward to the right with
velocity V what's the velocity of this
point right over here well the velocity
of this point it is going to have the
same magnitude but in the opposite
direction
it's gonna look something like that I
don't know if those lines are exactly
equal but these are supposed to have the
same magnitude and so you could even
imagine this would be you could say that
this would be a negative V just like
that but for the sake of our for the
purposes of this question I want to
think about its speed so the speed here
the speed here is just going to be V
again so the speed of this point which
is going to be the same as the speed of
this point the direction here is
different but all of these points along
the rim or along the outside of the tire
I should say are all going to have the
same speed speed V and we already have a
relationship that we've explored in
previous videos between speed and
angular velocity we have seen that speed
I'll do it in a new color here just I'll
say V for speed with no arrow not bolded
is going to be equal to the magnitude of
our angular velocity so the magnitude of
our angular velocity times our radius
times times our radius or another way of
saying this we could say that our speed
is equal to instead of writing it like
this let me just write just an Omega
without an arrow over it to say this is
the magnitude of our angular velocity so
that times our radius so here I'm
dealing with all scalar quantities I'm
saying speed is equal to magnitude of my
angular velocity times my radius so if I
wanted a angular velocity as a function
of speed I could just divide both sides
by r and so I could say angular velocity
is going to be equal to my speed over
over R so let's think about what happens
and let me be clear this right or this
distance right over here that is R that
is our right over there so if our
velocity goes to 2v so if this goes from
V to I'm just a different color if that
goes from v2 to V then this is going to
go from negative V to negative
to V and our speed is going to go from V
to just to V the the twice the speed and
if you have twice the speed if this goes
by two well then the angular velocity is
going to increase by a factor of two so
this is going to increase by a factor of
two you're not squaring this or
something else you're just multiplying
this by 1 over R yours dividing it by r
and r is not changing just the speed is
changing and since Omega is equal to V
over R if you double V you're gonna
double Omega so how does the angular
velocity of the wheels change well it's
going to double it will will double and
we are done